so did Linda fair steam really screwed
against I haven't seen it does she
really wrote to op-eds did you see the
two op-eds
I did I know she's she doubled down yes
instead of Manning up and going okay I
did a terrible thing I made a mistake
but these are the this is the evidence I
had in front of me I made a mistake and
let the kids go she doubled down and
saying well just because the DNA didn't
match well the DNA matched to the guy
who committed the crime who confessed to
the crime who said he did it by himself
if she still kind of went with the
original argument what which was okay so
he's the sixth one and the rest of all
morning off somehow that she's saying I
guess they were involved somehow but
maybe they didn't just the actual
grasping at straws yeah yet to double
down to protect herself yeah she lost
her book deals she was kicked out of the
all her boards yeah and then and then
letterer was kicked out by her students
at Columbia diversity who's the other
prosecutor with oh I mean there's like
this for me I think the scene that like
really just just just gets you is like
you see the youngest one Oh little kid
right you see the little kids or T and
this actor and they they go back when
they find them guilty they do this great
thing where they flash back to where
they were right before they got brought
in and you're like you're looking at
this little kid and you realize like he
thought he was this was just gonna be a
normal day like any other day he's a kid
he's walking down the street and all of
a sudden he's not gonna have freedom
again for a decade a child a 10 year go
even wrap your head around oh I'm
getting chills just now and then tearing
up I mean it's so painful to is that
tough for you to be in that war like
when you're an actor on that show
especially when you're playing one of
the dads did you meet the real dad yeah
I saw a lot of time with Raymond Santana
senior and the kid and I got all the
actors together with me and we spent a
little time together to bond to try to
understand how do we make this as real
as possible right because Ava also
called Linda Fierstein before we started
shooting and I was in the room when when
after the fact and Linda said I'm not I
have nothing to say and Ava said I want
to know what happened from your point of
view I have all this information I have
the transcripts from the court
transcripts I have the kids I wanted to
hear your point of view she goes
so she's mad about the way they
portrayed her but she was offered the
option one Oh like she come back and go
no that's incorrect that's not what
right right right she could've been a
part of it and shown her sorry but
obviously she was afraid
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]